about a month ago one of the biggest
streamers on the planet signed a
contract to stream exclusively on twitch
and chances are you didn't even know he
exists it caps off a decade of insane
growth and personal struggle with
burnout and now he streams to sixty
thousand people
every day who is he well let me tell you
by now you guys might have noticed the
score esports is streaming over at
twitch.tv slash the score esports
we got chess streams we got talk shows
we got pros versus plebs and we are
constantly thinking of new ways to keep
you guys entertained
so make sure you follow the channel to
know exactly when we go live
all right back to the story rubius
rubius c
l rubius oh my god he's a spanish
speaking youtuber
and one of the biggest twitch streamers
on the planet we're talking 60 000
concurrent viewers
and for the most part the english
language streaming world has no idea who
this guy is
and we're talking bigger than ninja big
in 2018
this guy streamed a hundred youtuber
fortnite match
that peaked at a million concurrent
viewers for comparison remember when
ninja and drake streamed fortnite back
in 2018 and the world lost its [ __ ]
mind for a couple of days
that stream peaked at 635 000 viewers
now because you might not have heard of
rubius before it's easy to think that
he's the new kid on the block or he's an
overnight success
but like a lot of content creators who
suddenly blow up
rubios has been grinding this out for
over a decade a grind that just a few
weeks ago paid off
huge as he signed an exclusive contract
to stream on twitch and
he poked fun at ninja in his
announcement video
he created his first youtube channel in
2006 making call of duty and skyrim
videos
both as a hobby and as a way to make his
friends laugh
but then some of those skyrim videos
cracked 100 000 views and kept
climbing helping him realize that maybe
youtube could be a full-time career
by the age of 21 that's exactly what he
did moved into youtube full time
and while his original channel took off
in popularity
it remained a place for gaming his early
videos were all over the place and
watching them now you get the sense that
he was figuring out what games he should
cover
and the type of commentary that he
wanted to provide basically
he was figuring himself out as a
youtuber but clearly he felt like he
could do
more as a person because in 2011 he
created his second channel el rubius oh
my god
which was dedicated to that vlog style
on youtube that we've come to know
from people like pewdiepie and even tifu
and holy [ __ ]
did it explode
spanish-speaking world of youtube and
twitch l rubios
is everywhere and his fans love him he's
sixth on twitch and total followers
and his combined 43 million youtube subs
make him the most subscribed spanish
youtuber on the platform on top of that
he's got his own apparel line
animated tv show and comic book series
called rubio's virtual hero
[Music]
by 2013 he capitalized on his youtube
success and started streaming on twitch
and in the last 90 days after steadily
growing his channel ruby has streamed to
60 000 average viewers
and it's not unusual for his stream to
peak at over a hundred thousand viewers
on a random wednesday in july
if you look at someone like nick merks
in comparison who's been streaming a ton
of warzone to thousands of people
and teaming up with dudes like tim the
tatman he only averaged roughly
36 000 viewers in that same time period
now rubio's style is bombastic and over
the top
sure but it's also understanding of who
his audience is
for example since his viewers are
largely young impressionable guys he
doesn't smoke or drink on camera
and his whole philosophy is basically
let's be good to each other stop being a
dick in the comments and on social media
on top of that he's adamant that things
like advertising and sponsorships
won't change his style or the content
that he covers
and he went so far as to make an
anti-censorship video to prove that
point to his fans
[Music]
now by 2016 this increasing popularity
led to an interview with time magazine
and on top of that it was the first
english language interview he had ever
given
quote despite his newfound celebrity
deblas gunderson remains humble
about his job i was doing this when i
was getting 400 views
getting 4 million is just a bonus above
all he wants his fans to know he is
still just a regular internet user like
them
if i am a leader then i'm a leader of
the weirdos he says
my videos say it's okay to be different
i think they make people feel less alone
end quote he followed up that time
magazine interview with having the most
retweeted tweet of 2016.
one that simply just said lemonade
iced tea it's with these people man
lemonade
redesign and on top of that fans could
take a virtual tour of his studio in vr
a project that he helped create in
collaboration with unreal engine
we talked with the guys of la frontera
and
they brought us with the idea of having
an experience inside
the rubio's room you can grab whatever
take whatever break
whatever and that that was the brilliant
idea but as that success
and popularity continued to build into
2017 and 2018
rubius hit a wall that a lot of
streamers are familiar with
burnout so he decided to step back
and take a break
and that break seemed to have paid off
since the first piece of content rubius
made when he came back
was that hundred youtuber fortnite match
that broke a million concurrent viewers
that [ __ ] is insane now the reality is
despite having millions of fans around
the world
this guy is not a big draw in north
america and i'm betting a lot of you had
no idea who this dude was before
clicking into this video and he's not
the only one who's huge internationally
but is virtually unknown to a north
american audience
look at german streamer the real nazi
he's a former
poker pro turned tv host turned gigantic
twitch streamer
who regularly streams casino and poker
games to over a hundred thousand viewers
and throughout the month of july he's
been the most
watched streamer on twitch regardless of
language
you might know him as the guy who
literally opened [ __ ] on stream during a
fan mail segment
another example is iran plays a
spanish-speaking streamer who primarily
plays gta rp
and has a youtube channel with 23
million subscribers
and then there's squeezy a french
variety streamer and popular youtuber
often referred to as the french
pewdiepie
i mean the list goes on and the fact is
it doesn't matter how much you watch
twitch there's always going to be
another 40 000 viewer streamer out there
that
you've never heard of and honestly
that's one of the coolest parts about
twitch and so yeah that's rubius he's
the ninja of spanish streaming he's the
michael jordan
of spanish youtube and chances are you
had never heard of him before clicking
into this video
i'm going camping this weekend you guys
like camping
keith alex you ever been camping i
[ __ ] love camping dude
i haven't i have a an overwhelming love
of camping yeah i'm going i'm going
camping this weekend i'm [ __ ] stoked
i don't really know what it is about
camping that i love so much but i just i
enjoy it
you know i like nature i like nature i
like going on on nature walks with my
camera you know taking photos of
i do live in a condo but that's uh